you grew up in a suburb on the south
side of Chicago how do you think that
affected you like during this time well
I grew up in a suburb and there is all
the difference it had I grown up in the
south side of Chicago were both of my
parents were at the actual city my
experience would have been a lot
different because I was in a suburb but
it was a new suburb it was the manifest
destiny of people who lived in Chicago
and it go south and into the create
these suburbs and we were the original
settlers in 1960 and we were I wasn't
even aware of the Vietnam War and you
know I was 10 in 1970 so you think I
would have I kind of vaguely heard about
it my parents didn't talk about it at
the dinner table I wasn't aware of
anything going on and it wasn't until I
moved out here to Los Angeles I live in
Laurel Canyon and and I became familiar
with what went on here like musically
and politically in the time I was
growing up and I had no idea so you know
I was in kind of a bubble and I think
being a being gay it you kind of you
have to you have to be get out of your
comfort I think that that just demands
that you step away from where it's safe
because you can't fully express yourself
if you stay there so you know I was
after college I went to the city and and
learned a lot more and you know what
compelled me to move to the city was the
fact that I probably couldn't be gay and
Dalton Illinois opened but I could be in
the city so I just I'd to stove right
into it and I learned a lot I mean
that's a whole other thing to like just
and you mentioned in marvelousness Mazal
like even being a woman that can be very
difficult being gay can be very
difficult it's all those it's like if
you think of I think it's sometimes
people aren't impacted unless it
directly impacts you so you just have to
rephrase it being gay in a place that's
that's not generally acceptable or PEEP
it's a fear people are fearful of it or
just don't know it like that that's a
whole that's the same kind of thing in a
sense of like not feeling safe to be
yourself not feeling safe outside of
your home you to move to a different
place that's that's ridiculous
like all of that is insane to me and I
just I just thank you because I actually
do
see you on Twitter quite a bit subscribe
to my channel subscribe to my channel
subscribe to my channel subscribe to my
channel please don't make me keep going